of the rush he's got Pon behind him but tried
the shot instead looked like Pon was a gim me
pass there so perhaps buffo gets a break besser
drops it off far Circle shot saved by Lucan and
he tuck Thompson and middle stat trying to
keep it into the Vancouver Zone but it's
forced outside towards Center by Oman and the
puck back into the Vancouver Zone middle stat
takes his shot pad saveing the rebound Alex tuck
trying to get the hands free he's got the puck to
the Corner Middle stack back to tuck far side of
the ice Sabers work it up top Conor Clifton shot
stop and middle stat in the high slot but with
traffic in front of him slap told that it was
blocked laery for Vancouver lifting It
Outside The Zone as the change here's
Conor Clifton on the right side sends it
to the net and that is going to be held
on to by Demco with 1411 to go here
and a score was first on 130 Times
short this is Hughes just inside the line far
Circle shot Lucan and got a piece of that one
off the shoulder and out to the wall and it'll
be cousins to Center fakes the shootting carries
it in lays it off for Greenway and the shot
is stopped by Dem Co the far wall up top for
Brock fesser he's got 10 on the power play so far
for the Vancouver kuu shot for the high slot seen
and stopped by ekal it back for Vancouver pass to
the middle of the ice picked up and tipped ahead
by Dakota Joshua but the Sabers Now find Benson
down the right side his shot had save right back
towards Benson he fights off Meers Benson sends
it back to the line first shot it's tipped in
front but it comes to the near wall racing over
Robinson good bump in front and tipped right on by
Benson and a save by Demco to keep it one nothing
Myers and he's the one that going to come up with
the pock going to get it to the front and then
the redirection there in front by Robinson but
a nice job by Zack Benson 510 Zack Benson versus
68 to Thompson down low against Garland as well
Middle St far Corner looking for tuck who chests
that one down then try to feed it back towards
Thompson tuck along the goal line near side
shot rebound for Thompson right in front gets
a whacky at it it's still in his feet Thompson
has it dangles in the corner lays it back clean
middle stat shot bouncing in front middle stats
got the rebound near Circle Casey still with it
working it out of the phone booth for tuck up
top to power Far Side Great move for the shot
that time by Ryan Johnson looking for the puck as
well the Big Fellas Sabers Now using their speed
to gain the Zone again Rasmus doen touch pass to
the slot and a quick shot and de goes coming up
big here in the first period that time on petka
the conu taken away and here comes Vancouver with
pon on the left side Pon forced behind the net by
Eric Johnson sends it in front big save made by
Lucan and rebound than couver so far held to four
shots in this opening period Puck lifted deep into
the Buffalo Zone laughy racing after it laferty
shot stopped by Lucan again far post Myers deep
in the Buffalo Zone sends it in front it's chent
wide and credit again kyopo he got on the back of
Bluer in a hurry Garland away from a check near
side shot off the outside of the post by Joshua
got to get one or two off here yeah jurgenson
and Samson shot stopped by Lucan and the puck
lifted out to center right so you got to be aware
of that because they like coming from the low side
and hitting that guy in the middle of the ice R
between the hatch marks canot slip the puck shy
of Center they've got three on the Counterattack
p with the shot scores from the top of the right
Circle Brock besser picks up his 28th of the year
and it's a one- nothing Vancouver lead let's take
a look there is the puck there's the feet oh yeah
that's over that's you see Nine's feet that's way
over before the puck enters the Zone yeah I
would agree gay and so the referees linesmen
will head to the Penalty Box here and I think this
is going to come is challenging the previous goal
for an [Applause] [Music] offside so the puck keep
an eye on the end of the stick you see the snow
coming up and the Puck's just on the end of the
stick following the skate and yes it's definitely
behind the skater there's no doubt about that
it's behind the skater they want to make sure
they can without a doubt see the puck he's picking
up the puck after video review the call on the ice
has been overturned offside no goal he reset
the clock to 1924 Conor Clifton racing after
it ahead of Joshua and the puck brought out the
near side of the net Joshua to the front of the
goal and a quick shot by Miller over on the goal
line to the right of Lucan spins away from two
Sabers Defenders then Ryan Johnson will play it
up the wall kept in shot to the net it's block
scored on the rebound standing in front of the net
laer was able to get to it and he puts Vancouver
up one nothing see where laery is in front was
there any contact with the goal tender in this
one let see the referee there he is you
see that left elbow just hitting Zadora or
I'm sorry Lucan in the head right there at
the last sack just right there it does hit
him in the head and he's in the and then
steps around and you you still see Matt
Alice there on the bench talking to the room and
when there's goal tender interference that's a
Mike Bales call Buffalo able to come away with it
Ryan Johnson sends it ahead racing after it is gar
getes to the net trying to go short side he almost
did and start doing your research as to who played
defense here I think Z because garson's here is
drop back and he's going to roll defense here
with Conor clipon just going to say see who's done
this before Lucan in gets some help from the goal
post there's another Defender helping out as it
Canucks with a quick counter on this four on four
Luca is stick save and a pass save as it steered
to the corner Sabers on a top change right there
got a little confused at the bench with a short
on D kale comes in bang right off the crossbar
there gets a little help UPL does from his post
will'll take both of those options into play as
Garland works it in over the line W for me out
of the corner far Circle shot looking it out to
Chalin makes the save way out of the net and he
covers up keeps it on the back wall along with
Greenway he'll play it back to the point Sabers
need to start getting Puck to enco there's one
and Bs it in front not inside from MV hip check
there by Greenway just enough back the other
way Ryan Johnson drags a shot through a blocker
save by [Applause] Demco that's lifted down into
the near Corner Quinn for Thompson behind the
net Thompson thinks about coming out sends it
in front middle stat shot is stopped by Demco
again kyoso to take the draw in the offensive
zone comes back to darene fakes the shot
fire Circle off the bar out of play comes
back darene slides it across look at how he's
locked and loaded already on the far side Doan
cousins he wants it he wants it bad and
what a shot right there just right off
the top side of the bar hand chance to lift
it out and Greenway had Center volleying at
it but Suter is the one able to play it ahead
his MCO trying to dance his way to the net he
does save by Luc to the pucks right in front
of the net down to the corner petka spins it
far Corner Quinn against heroni who gets position
on the ponic kicked it forward and now right in
front and a one timer by petka stop by Demco
you're looking for one big play and they're
able to produce it and that a shot right on JJ
pka's tape and he let it go and Demco able to
make that safe yeah it's at 4.6 again here
4.6 now all right Kyle POS on the face off
Sabers win the draw backand of the net steer
to the far wall one more chance and the kucks
hang on well the Savers put up quite a fight
here they fall one- nothing against Vancouver